well here in germany the health system
is still coping well but the country's
vaccination program
continues to be dogged by problems after
a crisis meeting with regional leaders
and representatives of the pharma
industry
german chancellor angela meckel urged
germans to be patient
she said most would be offered the jab
by the start
of the autumn only around 2 million
people have so far received a covet
vaccine in germany
the rollout has got off to a slow start
on
monday political leaders spent the
afternoon discussing with the bosses of
medical firms
how it can be speeded up but despite
delays chancellor merkel repeated her
clear promise
does via this end by the end of the
third quarter
by the end of the summer we'll be able
to offer every citizen a vaccine
that said the manufacturers have also
told us today
that something that they can't foresee
can always occur
during production and they also all have
no prior experience of this
but i think the numbers for the
different quarters overall
are already very relevant
one reason the chancellor is confident
she can achieve her targets
is that the producers predict they will
make ever more vaccine
official projections suggest the
government expects a total of 322
million doses will be available this
year
but production cannot be ramped up
immediately the current shortages are
likely to last for at least two more
months into the second quarter
looking back the eu approvals process
was slower than in some other places
in part because it insisted on full
approvals
rather than provisional ones the
chancellor
defended that cautious approach
we are guilty money would not have
created more capacity
the order from biontech was in fact
rather large
the americans have more options but our
initial order of 200 million doses was
very high
and we had hardly begun to look at the
production site in marburg in germany
when the european commission was already
negotiating a second contract
but such explanations are likely to be
of little comfort to people especially
the elderly
who have been told to expect to get the
vaccine but are so far
struggling even to get an appointment
the important thing is that the
vaccination date is truly reliable
people get really frustrated when the
appointments cannot be kept
because of delivery bottlenecks and
limited resources
that is what annoys people not so much
that they might call up and ask
five times frustration
is growing as the lockdown drags on
the government has set out a pathway
back to normality with promises of
vaccine
now they will face even more pressure to
deliver
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent melinda crane here melinda
there was massive pressure on german
political leaders at this
vaccine summit to deliver more than just
words
did they well you know one german
newspaper
is calling this the placebo summit
but i think that's wrong a placebo has
no
effective ingredient and at this summit
a very
effective ingredient was produced and
uh exchanged namely more facts and more
information
it was clear from what we heard uh in
the press conference
that the politicians at both federal and
state level
had not fully understood the
complexities of the supply chains of the
pharmaceutical firms some of which
took part in the summit it was also
clear that the
federal government hadn't fully
understood
the state's need for more reliable
information for planning purposes even
if that information
includes the fact that vaccine
quantities in this
part of the year until the second
quarter will be lower
than many politicians had hoped so what
we saw
at the end was the politicians coming
together
to say that they understand now what
the supply situation is that they will
develop a more detailed road
map for uh the rollout by the middle of
this month
and we saw essentially more reliable
facts and information
both for policy making but also for the
public which is exactly what we heard
the person in the report calling for
chancellor mackel says that uh all
germans will have access to
a vaccine by the end of the third
quarter that's
eight months from now how realistic
is that and how is that message being
received
actually she's promising that all
germans who want to be vaccinated
will have that opportunity by the end of
the summer
and the various tables of vaccine
deliveries that were produced as a basis
for discussion at this summit
absolutely bear her out as we heard in
the report
the vaccine quantities will remain
limited in this first quarter the
government's been saying that all along
the next eight weeks
will remain difficult but after that
vaccine delivery will pick up
significantly
70 million uh by the end of june
and 126 million doses throughout
the summer so basically it looks like
the chancellor absolutely
is right and experts bear her out on
that
melinda thank you very much that was our
chief political correspondent melinda
crane
now to the coronavirus crisis the
pandemic is pushing hospitals
in portugal to the brink of collapse the
country has
the highest number of new cases in the
world mainly because
of the new british variant of the virus
spreading out of control the
situation is so critical that other
european nations are now coming to the
country's aid
spain and austria have offered help
germany is sending
a team of doctors and equipment this is
the second field hospital being built on
this university campus in lisbon within
a few days
this time the basketball court is being
converted into a temporary clinic for
150 covet patients
joao roquette usually runs the
university sports facilities but in
recent weeks
he has also been working as an emergency
helper
the sport facilities they are very
flexible
and it's very easy to adapt the sports
soul
to a field hospital more difficult is to
put inside
the human resources for to running
the this kind of hospital
doctors from germany are among those
preparing to work at this temporary
corona hospital
they are part of the medical team from
the german military that is set to
arrive in portugal
on wednesday lisbon's largest hospital
right across the street from the
university campus has been under massive
strain for days
almost all of portugal's intensive care
beds are occupied
and there is an acute shortage of
equipment the pressure on portugal's
health system
seems to become unbearable ammu lenses
often have to wait for several hours in
front of the hospitals
before their patients can be admitted
and many fear
that in the coming days numbers will
continue to grow
joao roquette is getting things set up
for the staff of the makeshift clinic
he had mobile homes installed for the
medics to take breaks during their long
exhausting shifts the mobile home
project began
two weeks ago and is already supported
by more than 200 volunteers
and 50 vehicles
the work here is pretty emotional last
week a doctor knocked on my door and
wanted to thank us
she said she often felt desperate i
think in addition to a place to sleep
the medical staff sometimes need moral
support
the volunteers think that solidarity is
the one positive thing
to have come out of the crisis and the
fact that germany and other european
countries are now offering help is
giving an international dimension
to that feeling of solidarity
let's take a look at some of the other
developments in the pandemic
investigators with the world health
organization are searching for the
origins of the coronavirus at an
animal clinic in wuhan china this could
provide
insights into how the virus might have
crossed from animals to humans
the u.s is ordering millions of rapid
home tests for covet 19.
they can detect the virus in 15 minutes
with 95
accuracy and schools and stores in
austria
are set to reopen next week officials
say the students
will be tested regularly for
face-to-face lessons
wearing masks and social distancing will
still be required
at retail stores